come fa questo gioco a essere mi costato
tre dollari sono un tizio nel deserto
pesa 13 mag a sto gioco ragazzi
incredibile vuoi vedere cos'è
lascio anche la vita li faccio bevo baby
baby a quelle la sete che figata
pochi se sapete aia mi ha morso sono
avvelenato
quindi io devo cercare di andare al alla
che c'è un'oasi la vedono quando
all'oasi mi riprendo un po di vita
giusto 13 mag a di gioco ragazzi carlos
a raccogliere un sacco di roma come
possibile lo stracco in un sacco di roba
ho trovato delle armi io comunque se ciò
che si chiama the run per quindi
calciatore di lepri stefano che è bell
ed è fatto benissimo per 3 euro
i take cose compreso qualcosa quindi non
sono morto
ma come a questo quarto ma dai
va dai a perché mi aveva appena nato lo
zio e quindi io dovevo mezzo la morte li
facciamo rigiochiamo
ne aveva avvelenato il serpente quindi
quando ti avvelena il serpente tu devi
trovare l'antidoto sonori schiaffi
schioppi apprendi niente se già vicino
al nostro punto di arrivo ok con se
quella roba laggiù raga lo vedete anche
voi c'è una cosa che cammina un
bruttissimo tizia prendere le cose per
terra
234 prendi tutto l'arco c'è un arco
prove delle senso a combattere contro lo
zio è non ne sono sicuro
ma vediamo se riesco a fare qualcosa di
decente la prendi questo titolo che c'è
per terra ok a posso fare un back che
sono fu nel non posso fare il back
bekhti colpisco ciapalo madonna che ciò
non si è fatto nulla
occhio o mio dio madonna che schivata no
mi piace male è fortissimo
madonna è difficilissimo pirla l'ho
preso l'ho colpito l'ho colpito quasi
nel punto al centro
no ragazze schioppa madonna che mira
proprio lui ci azzecca e caccia come si
deve mamma mia cosa ho fatto l'ho
trovato tratto delle piume cosa mi ha
dato
inventori che ho avuto per le scarpe
parco demonio vi servono altri tre di
questi rom escape va bene o ragazzi
questa è una bela ranera attenzione ci
prova dalla distanza
minchia no no cos'è e notte
porca vacca gol ma dai ma poi l'ho fatto
bene no l'ultimo va bene la gente guarda
che c'era è questo c'era porca vacca
cioccio allo sprint dallo sfruttare lo
sprint
maledizione ti prego un ciclo no ma
porco demonio di precisione eccolo
d'aequa nome non ci credo o non è morto
pure pure di cure più di una freccia
devo ficcare ma con cavi per terra
stecchito per cortesia mori quanto ti
devo colpire basta avere sta rallentando
quello che prego sta funzionando
eccolo è andato giù
quindi pur cosa fu leghe sa cosa mi è
servito per poi non mi ha dato niente
nomi di s p roma non lo so cos'è che ti
dà inventori dominato una mazza però
potrei fare un back pack con delle robe
che non fa niente ci siamo raga la mega
fi
ritorna devo sempre utilizza non è vero
che basta serpenti basta aiuto porca che
ti portano occhio tutto questo perché
devo scappare al serpente no devo andare
lì dietro maledizione occhio che prima
era pure veloce che sono i miei più
difficile porte ma che vola velocità era
molto più easy sono vivo ok
proviamoci 1 bene partenza ottima 1 bene
uno bene
ottimo ragazzi tutto a posto
ma poiché in faccia questo non volevo
troppo forte volevo farle un po più
testate che ci hanno al centro le pance
segnale thank you
bene due non ce l'ho più
meno male ne ho ancora 3 ar
cliccate qua per terra 147 [ __ ] occhio
in questo tira meraviglioso poniamoci
demonio
devo stare attento non parole troppo in
là perché sono poi non le so che
riprendo lo bello questo bello no di
pesca mi pesta aiuto da fatti un sacco
di danni
bellissimo devo andarci sotto e
tirargliela non è male ma l'ho colpito
un sacco di volte come primo dovrà
riuscire a beccarne al treni freccia due
sono libertà era dall'altra parte ok
occhio che se sbaglio mi ha poi
prenderle un casino vai proviamoci preso
buono ruolo madonna riprendere veramente
difficile che è successo e giorno una
battaglia durata giorno e notte
[Musica]
madonna che bello il sole resort madonna
ragazzi meglio imbattibile non va mai
giù ai ha colpito di nuovo basta mori
madonna non muore mai ragazzi cioè mi ha
fatto malissimo
ora quante lino ficcate hai avuto ok che
sono schivata colpi perché chiuse
lontano più facile di vari
facile un parolone ai porco demonio
quante frecce per tirare giusto
christian a maverick e si è ridotta la
vita in mezzo a ok non avevo visto
occhio che occhio in modo non so mi sta
veramente molto seri doppio fuso nel
mezzo
no no no è no te ne devi stare a casa
tua a casa tua che già è difficile porco
demonio si serpenti morissero tutti
incidente stradale un'esplosione atomica
ma porca maledizione la vita quotidiana
ci ho provato veramente difficile
proprio gli sia piaciuto ragazzi un culo
quale episodio iscritti al canale
schiacciatela calvo alle li na prima
della giornata di video che estero e noi
come sempre ci vediamo al seguito dai
ragazzi
[Musica]